I have a little like added question to
this you know one of the things that
kind of caught my attention in this is
and she's like my goal is not to make
money I just want to make a difference
and I find it just based on the little
that i read about what she does she also
has a nonprofit that helps women and
children like I find that for anyone
who's in kind of really really has a
heart for service and I don't know how
to put that in one category but it can
be uncomfortable to do what you love and
then also have a desire to make money
doing it can you speak a little too like
anyone who has trouble with the part of
like helping but also being able to be
paid for what you do I think almost
everybody growing up has some kind of
belief around money that that is hurting
them almost everyone you got you got
some people who money is everything to
them and they're just chasing it and
they get all their meaning through money
which isn't great I mean you got other
people who shun money and say and feel
like they don't deserve it and that it's
wrong there aren't that many people
growing up who have a balanced
perspective on money and somewhere along
the lines we have to figure it out for
ourselves hopefully and so if you're on
that other side where you see money is
almost evil or you don't deserve it or
you know I'm just trying to give feet
I'm just trying to help people you know
I don't I don't want to get paid there's
nothing wrong with getting paid right
yeah like there's nothing wrong with
Ernie mighta money is good it's not
everything but but it's not evil either
right and and making money allows you to
do other things not just for yourself
but for the world for the community that
you're giving back to for the impact
that you try to make first is just a
mindset any words because when people
don't have that or they're on the other
hand again where they're just so all
about money but they don't have any they
don't care about adding value they don't
care about the servicing cure understand
that as you are adding more value you're
going to start being getting offers to
get paid to do things and then it's that
mindset that will pretend
hold you back or changing the mindset
will help you become the person that you
can be so what I'd be looking to do is
if you're doing sessions with people as
example if you're doing one-on-one and
trying to help somebody out or if you're
doing speaking right if you film those
videos and you get to be a good speaker
and you put it up on YouTube you'll get
offers to go and speak I get paid to
speak and you'll get offers to have a
book deal and you'll get offers to sit
on boards of companies and you'll get
offers to you know do a whole bunch of
stuff that you may not have ever thought
of and I know because this happened to
me you're right like I'm in this same
field as you are just serving a
different audience and so if you're
adding a lot of value and as you get
better you'll continue to get more and
more opportunities at you but out my
biggest fear would be that you would
turn them away because of the I'm not
trying to make money thing and that your
ability to have a bigger impact money
and self is not evil money is an
exchange of value if you get a book
opportunity if you get a speaking gig
you don't you can still do this stuff
for free you know there's a community of
people who you know can't afford your
your services you can still contribute
and help back I'll let you know I look
at trying to dance also an example you
know we charged for people to come and
learn salsa classes if we didn't charge
your people to come and learn we
wouldn't have a business it be you know
one person may be volunteering their
time and so that one person could maybe
reach you know how many people you know
a couple people a week instead we're
doing you know 5,000 people a year right
so because we charge we're able to have
a great impact and reach more people but
not everybody is able to afford it you
know we have people who are refugees
coming to the country and they don't
know anybody and they want to meet meet
people and kind of get under getting
understand how the culture works but
they don't have any money to do it or
university students or is a whole bunch
of you know different people in
different circumstances of what they can
and can't afford and so people are
really having a hard
time if they're asked for like a payment
plan or sometimes just for free you know
we have a bursary program where we give
away classes to people who can't afford
them for those people it's great they
have an opportunity to still learn and
benefit but there are a lot of people
who can also afford it right like if
you're dealing with people who are
getting divorced or trying to inspire
this women right it was just women yeah
telling women your story right there's a
lot of women who who can't afford to
come and listen to you speak and would
want to buy a coaching package from you
and we want to support you and what
you're doing and you know there are
people who write to my youtube channel
saying hey how can I support you
financially because I love what you're
doing and if you say no I don't I don't
do it for money like you're not just
taking away from yourself you're taking
away from your audience because you
could use that money to hire somebody to
help you and you're taking away from
that person who wants to give you money
right well that person wants to give you
money to support you and your you're
taking that opportunity away from them
and a lot of times we don't see that and
and so soon as you some kind of
condition that comes early on in our
lives about money is evil or you know
usually come to our parents some of
their family and so money is itself
again is not evil it allows you to do
stuff but it doesn't mean you have to be
a sellout like do things on your own
terms do things that always make you
feel comfortable and that are sticking
to your integrity money is good you know
for people who don't like who shun money
money is good money is not everything
there's nothing wrong with making money
and using that to go out and have a
bigger impact on other people's lives
too very cool Thank You heaven